this is uh this is where the virus is
spreading these came from literally the
the thought process was I originally
said one of bitcoins greatest qualities
is that it's captured I said the mental
energy of a generation right people were
so excited and the talent was flowing
into the space the capital was flowing
into the space and so you get these boom
and bust cycles but innovation follows
that town in capital right because
there's just so much mental energy being
applied to it but what I worry about is
like we look at what happened with
retail in late 2017 early 2018 and this
is what I worry about is a ton of retail
investors got crushed absolutely and I
think the hard part is those people
aren't going to come back for a while
because their trust has been destroyed
and we did it through this financing
vehicle where we created a bunch of
wealth under the guise of
decentralization that really flowed into
the hands of a few people and you see
this right reflected in like all these
crypto conferences and like people going
to exotic locations and living really
lavish lifestyles and then this gets
glamorized which brings in you know less
educated wave of retail and I find that
a bit problematic the crypto has a
little bit of an image problem and yes
like the sexiness like the sex drugs
rock and roll appeal of crypto is
definitely there but I think it's a
double-edged sword because a lot of
people have gotten really burned and I
think a lot of people look at it and
they're like yep well if you think in
the last 12 months so we're doing this
August 2018 so August 17 right is really
when I think kind of the more mainstream
audience started to at least hear about
it and then you go into October really
November December and then you look at
the price depreciation since those days
there's a possibility that more people
lost money investing in Bitcoin the last
12 months then made money right on an
aggregate number of investors absolutely
I have so many stories from retail
investors and institutional investors by
the way who really got burned and I
think part of the problem here is on
people like stories right
where humans have an rich oral history
because we tell stories that's how we
share information that's how we connect
with other people so the story around
crypto up until January 2018 was this
everyone had a friend or someone they
knew who bought Bitcoin early or who
bought cerium early and they the asset
they bought went from X to Y and that
Delta was you know twelve thousand
percent five thousand percent and so
people look at that and they're like ooh
Bitcoin cerium Ripple people got into
these assets early that have been around
for five or six years they made 100 X
200 X a thousand X their money I want to
do that and then all of these i ce o--'s
are pitching
where the next etherium we're like
bitcoin but better and so people bought
it yep and then that doesn't materialize
I think this is the problem with growth
stories right and this is the way
equities market really you see it happen
there as well I'm it kind of reminds me
of penny stocks absolutely no and part
of it is your trading or gambling right
you know that if you look at 100 of them
but you get to say you're in a tech
investor right like it's a gamble
full-time I love gambling I would I tell
people I tell people that you can't you
can't claim you're investing if you
don't have a thesis you don't have
underwritten the risk and you don't have
a price target well and I think this so
this actually is a really good point
so people are so focused and investing
and this is true venture as well right I
worked a lot on the post investment side
people are so focused on everything up
to the point of writing a check and then
once they write the check they're like
okay my work is done no no actually your
most important job as an investor one
the investing process is about
controlling entry price yep and it's
articulating a thesis and a strategy as
an investor but as a fiduciary your
primary responsibility is that post
investment life cycle you have to
monetize it how do you track the status
of these projects right how do you
articulate a cogent thesis on where your
liquidation points are and how do you
periodically rebalance and D risk and
take out some of the principal and then
reinvest how do you think about your
role in the governance
so these companies that you're
capitalizing and was so funny to me he's
like I've been doing this in the venture
world with the portfolio companies I've
been working with for the last five
years and now I'm crypto funds are like
oh like maybe we have to be partners to
these projects the way I feel like I'm
taking crazy my taking crazy girls um I
think so it's just really interesting
the naivete and just and again I sound
like a skeptic but I just I feel like
we're not learning lessons I feel like
we're so unwilling to accept fundamental
truths about human nature that we're
forgetting that like hey when you write
a check like what's part of the
revolution right is if you go from you
know step one to step 7 you don't get
the benefit of learning what two three
four five and six actually the other
thing is people have gotten away with
free riding right both in their
diligence process some people are like
oh if Andreessen invested a few in us be
invested I'm an amazing so that's
there's free riding on the investment
process side where people basically do
no work and are able to race crypto
funds and then the second component is
there's a lot of free riding in the post
investment process and it happens in
traditional venture which why everyone's
like Oh find a strong lead because I
don't want to do the work let's have
someone else who is more capitalist to
do the work to help you grow something
in crypto world right Lee and the
problem is when you have a bunch of
investors who are free riding off of
everyone else and they don't actually
own equity they just own tokens which
are liquid right away what's the
incentive to actually help people
long-term and this I feel bad for
projects who raised money from investors
that basically sold their souls to raise
this money and then as soon as the token
lists everyone dumps the token takes
their cash out and they're trying to
build so they're like passionate about
building a vision and everyone who told
them they were also passion about it
just stopped them I think they're like
cool we got our cash buy and that's not
a good paradigm either so I do feel bad
for companies who have a big vision
we're trying to build it like that's why
I think a lot of these projects who
didn't set a date for releasing their
token they're probably better served to
not release their token until they've
gotten the max juice out of their
investors